coach k says that when you first start
the game you look at that chess piece as
you you are the king on that board i got
this tattoo approximately a year ago i
got the king face and my girl got a
queen piece
technically i'm really playing unless i
come to jail that's the only time i
really been playing a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
much
my name is elwood dawson i'm from
chicago i'm sika blackman my name is
roberto beza junior and what i want to
share is i love tacos taco
success so yeah
[Music]
with the chess program really even chess
in general like on the deck
you uh
you kind of lose yourself you don't
really think about your case
you learn to think differently you know
you strategize more
i sometimes come out
uh 7 30 in the morning i'll probably
play until lock up you know so it makes
my day go by faster
it's competitive it's a lot of trash
talk
is it's crazy you know like the chess
players we got our own little circle and
all of us play each other we talk trash
about who be who who garbage
yeah i never play that dude again he
garbage i have a plan
it is real competitive
[Music]
all right gentlemen you can have it sit
randomly right now then it'll start
moving a little bit
that's all
where is mr bell
he did it on coppers
i i knew it
all right
so
the first game was played in 1620
now a few years ago my name is mikhail
korenman i am
currently
employed by cook county sheriff's office
i strongly believe
that chess
helped everyone
to feel
i am the winner right now i wanted i did
it i did it by myself i did it without
any bribery any help
and i'm the winner
develop the pieces go to the center
don't dispose your king
okay but that was played in 1620.
okay let's look what happens in 2004.
at first it was hard uh it took me a
long time to win my first game and i'm
about to quit so many times and i
actually won my first game and that felt
good and
just kept going from there coach k is
actually he's a pretty cool teacher you
know he's very experienced he can play
without even looking at the board you
know that's what really amazes me a lot
i learned a lot from him i learned that
chess is bigger i thought it was just
like
a regular game at first
but
he said he went to all these different
countries and played chess and i'm like
what he just came from over overseas
francesc he talked trash i did not know
it because he owed him like our first
time meeting him he playing he playing
us so he talking trash i'm like what
this old man
yeah he's still talking trash oh yeah he
actually had one game one against me
that's why he's putting it so hard
to get a documentary that he can win
well he can he can
he did
he even gave me a check
i got a feeling you got a feeling
checks help you open up your mind get
your mind to a whole another different
level
you want to develop in life you want to
open up your mind so other people can
see you
be that leadership
[Music]
look you took this pawn
why didn't you take this pawn
you cannot move this pawn
dr cornerman i got to be friends
years ago because why he was the
individual that
no connection to me whatsoever he was
working for the chicago public school
system
not as an employee of theirs but as a
contractor who would teach chess at
different locations well he ended up
teaching chess at my son's grade school
the sheriff said oh i like to have this
program in my organization
and i said sure when do you want to
start and he said what do you mean when
tomorrow
i had no idea that this program will go
for 10 years as of now
and will be involved
thousands of inmates
four five six
white pawns stays on a white square
we do have one female division in our
jail
i just started the project there um two
months ago
the kid the king came out
it's good it's a lot of women here who
never played it that's in the program
but they learn a lot and they actually
like it at first they thought it was
boring they just wanted to see what it
was like
if they give us a chance to play with
the man i most definitely would
right yeah
they need to i'm asking can you set some
up
there's always this conflating of
prisons and jails is one of the same and
it's not just something where
you're technically wrong and i'll
correct you is no their purposes are
completely different a jail is where
people go to wait their trial
prisons on the other hand are where you
go to serve a sentence
whereas in a jail
you're waiting on a trial and that could
be
months it could be years and so as a
result of it
operating in jail is much more complex
jail population is constantly
moving so our chess team is very
you know very open
group
[Music]
the majority of people that were being
held in the jail went straight from the
jail back to the community
the notion was is that because you're
just a temporary holding place
that there's no real reason to do any
programming or anything like that
because they're all going to go from
your jail down to the prison and that
couldn't be any further from the truth
the vast majority went to the community
and so for me it was
more than that it was always going to be
more than that it was trying to give
people
not just the skills in this really
interesting game but so that the way
they think changed too
[Music]
man we just played like three games he
up two games man right now it's a four
to one streak my way
we haven't played possibly in probably
about a week but he enjoys playing chess
too
me and him actually learned around the
same time and you know it's been fun
watching him grow he's early on he'll
treasure his queen off too he doesn't
mind losing his queen but he uses his
horses more
i'll be i'm a little mad if you take my
horses because they they the deadliest
piece on the board
everybody thinks it's the queen but it's
the horse because
you can't defend it gathered some boards
over there chest clocks over here
you're all in all right
[Music]
like white black
chess is everybody said all the time
it's a lot like life you got to be
patient you got to stay focused
and just got to be aware
i just learned to you know be careful
and you have to make
sacrifices in order to get where you
want to go you just can't you know
have one option there's always a lot of
options
one
research was presented at the university
of texas in dallas
a number of years ago it was presented
by
brazilian team
general in the country of brazil it's 72
percent
72 percent of the prison population at
some point of time getting back to the
prison
the research which the brazilian team
presented
showed that if prisoners stay with chess
for at least one year this rate drops to
from 72 to 48
with his chest
all right
yeah he got it yeah
good job yeah good job
i will see you all next week
all right
[Music]
for someone who
maybe does not know chess that well
would not see how clearly this fits
on so many levels as i say whether it's
transforming an individual's way that
they think
to
how this opens up avenues for
interactions within a family that in
many cases the interactions had never
been there in the first place
[Music]
okay we're ready for a small press
conference it is something that has
never happened anywhere in the world
before
to have correctional facilities all
around the world playing at once in a
chess tournament army is very proud to
participate in this tremendous event it
will be an honor for us to be part of
any of your future undertakings
last year we organized the first
international
intercontinental online championship for
for for prisoners it was 31 country
participating
40 teams
5 female teams i know without name in
the country
that some maximum security facilities
where prisoners
could not be
more than one in a room before i met him
i would never like that people do that
i think yeah it's chess competitions but
all over the world online throughout the
jails playing against each other that's
a whole different
thing like he opened that up
there was a incredible
level of anxiousness that was neat that
reminded you of how athletes would be
before the big game before the kickoff
but actually you know this tournament is
of course the flagship event for the
whole movement that we want to expand
for training these
people for carrying out research
[Music]
nobody could even believe
that zimbabwe and mongolia will play
a final round i had mongolia won the
championship
[Music]
i love dr corman and don't know what i
do without them i mean people often
underestimate individuals you know in
the sense of
that person
has
made these changes happen
and but for that person these things
wouldn't happen
that's him
[Music]
i
had an opportunity to go to
new york city
and
stop by
one or two i named them chess rooms
and they were packed
11 p.m midnight those rooms were packed
with people
i think that is absolutely fantastic
the city of chicago
don't have it
it's sad
we know well i know that bobby fischer
was born in chicago when he grew up in
new york
but still
the city of chicago should have more dr
corman's vision for quite some time now
and i bought into it immediately was to
try to figure a
method to come up with a
chess
center for lack of a better word on the
outside of the jail so for all the
different people that we've engaged over
the course of the years and many of them
we came in contact one way or another
would have a location where they can go
to on a regular basis yeah i want to
teach my kids how to play my my sons i
got three sons i want to teach them how
to play
i do want to get my daughters into the
to the chess clubs i know like at my
daughter's school they got a chess club
and she wanted to join two just to learn
so that's something i'll probably be
pursuing happy birthday to me i'm 24 my
kobe year
um
and
unfortunately i'm in this circumstance
but i'm gonna make it through
i won't be here next year for sure
good job
all right
[Music]
yes